>> Okay, Michael. So you think you know everything, so here's a
quiz. So, here are two matrices, matrix prisoner's dilemma and matrix bunch of
numbers that look vaguely symmetric but
aren't quite. So here's what I'm going to
ask you do do. In each of these cases find the Nash equilibrium.
>> Rut-roh. So do, you told me what it was but you
didn't tell me how to find them so that seems kind of rude.
>> It was implicit. It's intuitively
obvious even to the most casual observer.
>> Oh, well then, okay. So, and just to remind me now, each row
and column is a choice for one of the players or the other player.
>> Yeah.
>> And the first number in the pair is the row player,
or A's pay off and the second number is B's pay off.
>> Yes.
>> And we might need probability distributions, or we
might not, depending on what it takes to be a
Nash equilibrium.
>> Right.
>> okay, I don't [LAUGH] I'm not, it's not like I see the answer yet but it,
but I either will be able to find it,
or I won't. At least I understand the question.
>> Okay. And by the way, just to make it
easier for you there are pure Nash equilibria here, okay?
>> Hm.
>> Alright, so you ready?
>> Yep.
>> Just circle the one or underline it or whatever it is Pushcar
does to make it so that you can answer this quiz. You ready?
>> Totally.
>> Go.